day i played arena arena ball
i was on the tv show yeah i i i [ __ ]
love your life los angeles it's kind of
i'm a great funeral uh the i will have a
grave you know i would i created or
married i'm cremated or buried uh let's
no i don't want to go too deep in there
is it cool if i sell merch at your
funeral
can i tell you i want to sell tickets to
it i want to do i want to do i want to
stream it live
well you want to talk i'm looking i'm
looking to build a great i kind of want
to be there i'm looking to be i want i'm
looking up a great set i'm no sugar is
going to talk i'm going to [ __ ] make
sure rogan talks then i'm like the walk
out with 250 for the greek if you sell
it out we got a door we got a better
door deal than you would maybe 250 they
feel bad for you so you can get a better
door deal but you can here's the thing
burt let's fake your death so you can
see it we do the night before we do
anyway what a [ __ ] pub stunt god
that'd be amazing
dude let's catfish the greek why doesn't
someone who's been canceled why don't
they fake their death